for critics of Brazilian President Jaya
ball senado this rally was another
outrage perhaps the most serious since
coronavirus began he spoke to supporters
outside of the Brazilian Army
Headquarters many of them called for
Congress to be closed and even a
military intervention to get there and
his wish and enter the quarantine
measures imposed by many state
governments we don't want to negotiate
in anything
what we want is action for Brazil
[Applause]
desperate people to get back to work
despite Brazil already having the
highest rate of piranhas virus cases in
Latin America 70% will be infected if
not today then next week or next month
it's a reality we have to take care of
the elderly and those with health
problems the rest have to be careful but
have to work there's widespread
opposition to that and to him yesterday
there was a movement Brazilian
government governors 20 out of 27
governors of Brazil state governors they
have signed a document in coming in
defense of democracy and of course
repudiating also narrows participation
in that demonstration so that happened
yesterday and 20 out of 27 this is
significant there are more than 40,000
Kovach cases in Brazil hospitals are
stretched to the limit this video shows
one in the Amazonian city of Manaus with
bodies resting beside living patients
even as for the president spoke at the
rally he was coughing
he's angered many with his distaste for
social distancing but appearing with a
crowd some of whom called for the army
to intervene and support him brought
wider condemnation Brazil escaped
military dictatorships only 35 years ago
the next day the president seemed to
make a u-turn we don't need to close
anything what we have here is democracy
and respect for the Brazilian
Constitution but he still repeated his
call for an end to quarantine measures
in Brazil by next week John Holman
al-jazeera